the Joe Rogan experience because I'm
both of your veterans and both of you
I'm sure have things you agree on and
disagree on but you're you're in a
really unique position here you know and
and since you've been on the podcast a
lot of things have happened big the big
one is when you rightly called out
Kamala Harris on her her past and what
she's done and and then it seemed like
everybody's attacking you it's like that
opened up the floodgates and then
there's all these hit pieces on in me as
a pertinent for the outside is like wow
look at the Machine work look at the
attack dogs go like look at this like
very transparent ah so if you're paying
a tent if you're paying attention to
thing is if you're on the outside and
you watch it all happen then you go oh I
see what's going on but if you just
happened upon one of those articles yeah
you go ho she's an Assad supporter oh
she's a terrible person oh she's a this
and a dad and it was amazing it was
amazing to watch like I don't know I've
never met anybody like like you that's
run for president like I knew you when
people didn't know you that well and
then all sudden people know you way more
and now you're a kind of a household
name so to watch this process and to
watch all the machinery sort of move in
your direction and prepare oh it's very
interesting yeah I mean that that
literally is is our challenge here is is
we are up against the most powerful
overall political machine when you when
you look at this this machine that's
revved up their engines to try to you
know define me as something that cast
suspicion or doubts or whatever in
people's minds you know pushing
information that isn't true or all of
these different things and I think
there's a few reasons for it our
challenge is like yeah we are battling
the political establishment in
Washington and it's because I'm telling
the truth it's because I'm challenging
the status quo that they represent and
and that they've profited off for for a
very long time so you know my campaign
we don't take any contributions from
PACs or lobbyists
fueled completely by contributions from
individual people and they are out
spending us by many many multiples where
we need help to challenge their
narrative with the truth telling me
eight this is who I am this is why I'm
running for president this is the
experience in the background that I
bring to this job we've got to be able
to bypass that mainstream corporate
media and just go directly to voters and
what is the experience of being attacked
feel like god I feel like I'm used to it
so it's I mean it's just like it's it's
it's nothing that I've ever really taken
personally because I understand the
situation you know I understand that you
know whatever the smears are however
radical they are you know it shows me
that they feel threatened and they are
concerned about both the unifying
message that I'm bringing because we
have Democrats Republicans libertarians
independents who are joining this
coalition that that is fueling our
campaign and and it's a campaign of by
and for the people and and one that's
that's actually speaking the truth
that's calling for an end to these
regime change Wars calling for you know
a de-escalation of tensions between the
United States and other nuclear-armed
countries and end to this new Cold War
nuclear arms race actually hey let's
focus our limited taxpayer dollars on
actually serving the needs of our people
that that's really the message that
we're bringing and it scares the hell
out of them what's interesting is for me
again as an outsider it's it's a clear
clear recognition that what they want
versus what they say they want are two
very different exactly the Democratic
Party's party's always been like we want
a woman okay I got you a woman how about
a woman there's a veteran check how
about a woman that's a congressman how
about that congresswoman veteran
minority minority from Hawaii all these
positives these trying to dig up dirt on
you they don't have anything that should
be behind you
they should have wind and your
sails but the other thing they're saying
is that you know in order for democrat
to beat Donald Trump in 2020 you're
gonna have to be able to take Trump
voters away from him you're gonna have
to win over those independents who
stayed home in 2016 or even some of
those Democrats who voted for Trump
because they feel like our party has
left them behind guess what
check check check check we're doing all
those things and instead of saying hey
this is really something that maybe we
should get behind instead they're saying
oh my gosh there's something very
suspicious and weird about her because
she's actually stealing voters from
Trump that's yeah that's the big one
right has there ever been someone in
your position that's get gotten caught
in such a crossfire like to be taking
this much heat from the party that
you're you know trying to represent is
it seems I don't remember this happily
they thought Harris had a real shot and
she's sunk Harris's ship that's exactly
what happened I mean if you look at
there's a direct correlation between
where Harris was standing and where
she's at now in that debate it just you
put holes in her boat which which was
you know I was raising some very
important issues related to criminal
justice reform you know ending the
federal marijuana prohibition and
essentially pointing to to leadership
because we're all asking to to lead this
country and bring the experience that
each of us has that's very distinct and
different and and her whole campaign was
based on the premise of being a
prosecutor for the people being the
Attorney General here in California and
I you know I I okay you you've said
you're proud of your record this is what
you have done when you were in a
position to make a positive change for
the people instead you chose to do
otherwise and I think that speaks louder
louder than words when you had more
bullets in the chamber to because there
was other things you didn't even like
you didn't really touch upon her saying
to single mothers that she was going to
prosecute them and lock them up if they
didn't get their kids in skip and school
laughing as she did so yeah I mean
that's the I've seen her talk about that
as if it's a good idea yeah that this
was a good solution I mean here single
moms into with with the fear of jail if
their kid didn't go to school yeah
it's crap for that that's that's the
challenge of this this debate format
that's that's so frustrating is you know
you've got 60 to 75 seconds to get your
point across to be able to talk about
hey here's my position here's what I
would do with you know North Korea
here's how I would deal with you know
immigration reform in 60 seconds or less
[Applause]